and III don't know the specific
economics of it but i think the the wall
street journal again well point in news
corp property is is is a great example
of you know they are they do well in
terms of traffic and their online
advertising and they also have a very
healthy base of online subscribers i
think the challenge is again going back
to the idea of the distribution model
has changed you need to offer something
of unique value to users if people are
going to pay for it now the journal has
has great business reporting things that
you can't necessarily get anywhere else
the things that their their readers rely
on for for effort from them as the
source for this really crucial
information in this case information
that makes them a lot of money you see
this as well with things like bloomberg
and reuters that deliver directly to
terminals and traders information that
people can profit from or again that
they simply can't find anywhere else
what will not work i believe on the web
is any sort of commodity information i
just i just don't just personally I
don't see that working on the web where
before if your competitive advantage was
your means of distribution again using
the Buffalo example I was the only place
that you could get information on
Buffalo and now all that other
information is a click away and if it's
all the same information I think there's
too many sources out there both
traditional and new but again if if as a
source you have unique information that
I can't get anywhere else and in the
journal the FT consumer reports all
different examples of sites that have
really valuable information for their
end users I think there there's a place
for paid models
it really depends are there is no
there's no sort of silver bullet for for
any and all news organizations but it's
and and I admit its purpose somewhat
somewhat vague to say well you know what
is uniquely valuable to your end users
but it's going to depend on you know it
can be local information so now I'll
keep using the Buffalo Hayes example if
you if this is the place where you have
a community and information about
Buffalo that I can't get anywhere else
great but it doesn't have to be I mean
there's a lot of discussion about hyper
local and and and you know the local
advertising market and so sure local is
one way to slice it but it could just be
and if something else of her talk about
is you know in New Jersey all the
pharmaceutical companies that are there
so maybe there's an opportunity sure it
can be New Jersey but maybe it's also
this is the area of interest there is
pharmaceutical information somebody at
personal name Bob lime and he always
sort of talks about this is the sort of
these these these different verticals
that are there so it's really about fun
like what's the information that I have
what's the talent set that I have and it
can be the content is obviously a big
driver of it but it's also the user
experience to like how can I create an
experience that people can't get
anywhere else so part of that can be
community part of that can be technology
so I mean I think you're seeing this as
well with with different applications
whether it's the iphone or android
applications if things that things that
people can't get anywhere else which can
be content or can be two speeds of how
they interact with your content and
information how they interact with the
rest of the users on your site